If we add the two equations together, the x terms eliminate and add to zero. 15y
and negative 4y equals 11y and negative 75 minus 2 makes negative 77. We can
divide both sides by 11, so one 1y is equal to negative 7. We found y so now
let's go and find x. Remember we could use either of the original equations to
find the other variable. Usually it's best to use the original equations,
because sometimes we might have made a mistake when multiplying, so we don't
want to use these multiplied equations. I'm going to use the second equation, 5x
plus 2y equals 1. This is a great opportunity to pause the video. Maybe you can
try to find the value of x by plugging in to this first equation instead. See if
we get the same result. So I can take the value of y, which is negative 7, and
plug it in for y in this second equation. So I get 5x plus 2 times negative 7
equals 1. 2 times negative 7 is negative 14. Then we add 14 to both sides of the
equation. So 5x is equal to 15. We divide both sides by 5, so x is equal to 3.
This is great. We found our solution.